how should we look at these numbers I
mean it's their own forecast that
they're beating so maybe that's not so
impressive but they didn't miss it
sure and you take the victories even if
you set them up yourself you know but
the real the real factor is going to be
the Model X SUV coming in the second
half of the year and if that's on time
and and on target is probably more
important metric than what we saw for
the first half of the year and yet a
substantial difference Matt Miller in
terms of the growth rate that the number
I look at is sequential growth I don't
think year-over-year is you know more
about cars and I'll never forget but you
know or you'll forget more about cars
and all ever no but the year-over-year
thing I seems to me at this stage of the
company
the right way to look at it is
quarter-over-quarter if he was that fair
no yeah absolutely and that's the way
analysts in the industry are looking at
it as well you've got about a 15% growth
second quarter over first quarter so
even though they only sold about well
less than 40% of the cars they have had
forecasts for the full year they want to
sell about 55,000 in the full year and
they've only sold about 21,000 so far in
the first half they only have to grow
about 12 or 13 percent in each of the
next consecutive two quarters to beat to
meet their projections of 55,000 and
let's face it it's all about the Model X
for Tesla right now if it comes out in
in this current quarter or at least at
the beginning of the next quarter that
should put them easily at their target
at 55,000 because the demand is huge and
the orders have already flowed in for
that model I assume Kevin Tainan that
the way that these sales sort of roll
out is kind of like an oil well where
that the most production happens in that
right after the new release this is a
new car they started selling in the
fourth quarter they have big sales
they're slower growth in the second
quarter a little bit better growth in
the in the third quarter of the cars
sales that is the revamped all-wheel
drive vehicle is that fair to say that
when we see the Model X the biggest
quarter lose that first quarter when the
demand is high sure and you're gonna
you're gonna fill those back orders
those those customers that have put down
their depositor and waiting in line to
get the vehicle certainly not going to
be
another inexpensive vehicle just like
the Model S's and I think when that
model 3 comes out depending where those
those units are transacting out is going
to be the biggest deal in terms of
long-term volume growth you know very
difficult in terms of Model S and Model
X which probably will be you know close
to ninety thousand dollars in revenue
per unit as you add options you know so
if you're if you're looking for longer
term volume it's going to certainly come
at lower price points than what we're
seeing now in other words the hundred
thousand dollar car the seventy five
thousand dollar base or whatever for the
Model S but basically ninety five
thousand dollars is about the average
cost per car if there's any $90,000 SUV
you're saying the real market is for the
Model 3 the the Tesla 3 Matt Miller that
is expected well when is that expected
Matt Miller the Tesla 3 by 2017 they
should have them in production and be
heading out the door I was gonna say in
dealers Lots but it's not really doesn't
really work like that obviously I am not
sure how profitable that car is going to
be for them because keep in mind that
for the Model S for example which starts
at around seventy thousand without any
options and choosing the latest version
more than half of the cost of that car
is in the battery and I think a lot of
what Elon Musk and investors have been
banking on for Tesla is that battery
costs would come down or battery power
would double convoy wait wait so if half
the cost of a $70,000 car is a battery
half of seventy thousand a thirty five
thousand dollars which is the supposed
price of the Model 3
like they can't cut the cost to zero
maybe they can cut it 10% maybe 20% that
doesn't get to zero
well they hope obviously that battery
costs will come down and that battery
capacity will climb but it just hasn't
been happening in a way that Silicon
Valley is kind of used to you haven't
gotten as Moore's law of battery
capacity there is no mercy look Kevin
all right sorry I want to go back to
we brought it for a minute here about
the timeline of what Tesla said about
the shipping date of the model three
because I think this is really important
I don't think people are focusing as
much I think this is just me that the
timelines slipping because in March 2014
Elon Musk's that'll be in 2017 and then
later in February instead of be the
second half of 2017 and then in May said
be late 2017 and then the CTO put up a
slide that said it would be 2018 of the
company explained to me well full
production won't be till 2018 that
sounds to me like they're pushing this
thing out because they're not getting
the advances that they want Kevin Tainan
yeah and and look and to Matt's point
about model 3 being profitable obviously
that's not initially what's going to be
important it's that they get the product
to the market obviously the market
hasn't cared about profitability to this
point anyway it's about hitting
eventually hitting those volume targets
and and I agree you the range is
supposed to be 200 miles so you're not
talking about the battery pack that you
would see in a Model S or a Model X so
there will be cost savings there as well
but but it's it these are high hurdles
you know the gigafactory is a big deal
driving those battery costs down as a
big deal if you're gonna do a vehicle
that is targeted to start at $35,000 I
also want to point out you're an
investor or even an analyst here
watching Elon Musk you by now understand
the pattern that he maybe doesn't over
promise but he definitely promises
things a lot earlier than they come I
mean you see it in the Model X you saw
it in the Model S they have a pretty
standard habit of saying we're gonna put
a vehicle out this year and no we're
gonna do it next year and then it'll be
the first half of the new year after
that and the second half of a year after
that I mean this is normal you can
almost set your watch to how late they
are on every product release the
difference is the Wall Street analysts
are not doing that they are also
analysts are building their models based
on those numbers we have to